okay so we are broadcasting live on
youtube
and i am with arturo
and uh arturo has been a loyal youtube
viewer for a while now and uh i don't
know maybe about a month ago or two
months ago i wrote in to say evan i love
your videos and
we need to make these available in
spanish
and so he's been helping translate a lot
of the videos and uh comments on a lot
of the videos and it's been uh
a great source of positive energy
he wrote in uh
a little bit ago and said hey i have a
problem i'm launching my business i have
some questions and i thought hey let's
turn this into a google hangout so
others could benefit from it too
and uh so welcome arturo if you wanna
maybe just
introduce yourself
let us know what's up and uh let's get
into it
okay great thank you so much evan first
of all thank you so much for what you do
i think that
a lot of people like me out there we're
starting up uh we're trying to get help
or as much help as we can
and i think that what you are doing is
it's it can connect with everything that
we go through it's like real it's not
something that we're just maybe like
looking up somewhere and then trying to
figure it out it's just you go right on
to the point which is awesome i think
that that's gold right there um
basically what i
do is i've been a little bit of
everything
uh mostly i am i have a lot of
experience with call centers and uh
things like that and what i'm trying to
do is basically that
i'm trying to help people communicate
uh people that don't speak the same
language don't really need to have that
barrier so that's what i'm we're trying
to bring down as a company
um so it's more like interpreting from
one language to the other uh what we do
is that it's um the type of interpreting
that we do is called uh consecutive
interpreting somebody says something in
one language and then the interpreter is
on the line listening to the message and
when the message is finished then he
would just relay it in the opposite
language and so on so forth so it's a
conference call so what i'm trying to do
that is that but with an app
why do we need an app
we don't necessarily need an app per se
but
i think it's practical because for
example we're trying to target is uh
entrepreneurs or people that are
traveling
in general let's say you go to a
different country don't speak the
language you can access through your
phone instead of hiring someone over
there which could be that one you don't
have
probably enough reference to see if that
person is a good interpreter or you were
going to get a quality interpreter or
reliable you don't even know if that
person is going to show up so that way
is a lot more practical is a lot less
expensive and it's it just solves a huge
problem it just it's everywhere you go
it's on your phone
this is an established industry already
right like people hire these
interpreters
all the time this is a it's a it's a
business that already exists right
definitely you see a huge market is just
that you're probably not aware of it but
for example here in this in the states
it's mandatory to have
an interpreter when you go to a medical
point for example and you don't speak
english so it's right here in the states
it's
huge there's a lot of companies out
there that have uh interpreters over the
phone or in presence uh live
interpreters so that people can
communicate with doctors and nurses and
what have you can communicate with the
patients it's required by law you're
supposed to be able to communicate with
someone that you're seeing
in the health industry at least does
your
service solve that problem
like if i don't speak english if i'm in
spanish can i use your app and bring
that with me and connect with you or do
i need a person with me
no you that's exactly the point the
point is that the app would be the
person instead of the person you get an
app which is a lot more practical but
yes it does solve the problem by law so
by law if i have your app i'm good
the thing is that here in the states is
required when it's health-wise it's
required by law to have an interpreter
but in countries like for example latin
america in south america caribbean all
those countries over there they don't
really have
laws that regulate the kind of
interpreting or this it's a it's it's a
world that's starting recently so it's
just getting formed it's just you know
taking shape right now so there's not a
lot of regulations out there that you
could say but it's definitely necessary
uh there's a lot of conferences that go
on in different parts parts of the world
where they need interpreters for example
the un uses interpreters all the time
it's a it's a career that is requiring a
lot more people we're shore staff right
now so uh interpreters are being
summoned they're asking people like hey
we need professional interpreters
everywhere for a ton of different
languages
so it is already your business like you
do interpreting this is your business
already
i'm starting out as a business uh me uh
personally i do i am a contractor i do
interpretation for uh different agencies
but um right now i'm doing it in the
states
and who are the typical who typically
calls in who are the people who need
your services
uh the agency that i work through right
now the biggest one is uh people that
it's uh
like i said it's mainly english and
spanish right now uh what they do is
nurses that come home they go take care
of elderly people you know people that
can't take care of themselves so those
people usually don't uh sometimes they
don't speak the language very well so
they need to take uh into consideration
uh the fact that they don't so they get
an interpreter off the line for them so
nurses that go to
people's houses doctors appointments um
insurance calls
recorded statements for accidents for
example 9-1-1 calls so there's a bunch
of
scenarios that need interpretation
sounds like it's a lot of government or
insurance and health kind of related
calls
in the us it is uh what i'm trying to do
is take a more of uh informal you would
say kind of scenario more like an
emergency that could happen but more
like uh
meetings business meetings um you know
just your regular day-to-day things that
you have to do in a country where you
don't speak the language so it's more
like a practical approach
so you're really targeting
business people who are traveling to
spanish-speaking countries and they
don't speak the language
basically and but it could be vice versa
it could be
also spanish-speaking people that are
traveling to different countries that
they don't speak the language in those
countries so what do they do now
right now
they try to speak english most of them
do
but
there are problems where
when you don't have that fluency
they just basically wing it uh i'm
talking about like for example i saw i
went to an airline
airline office it was a asian person he
was trying to speak to the clerk she
only spoke english and spanish but the
clerk
didn't really thought that the
customer didn't really speak uh spanish
or english so
that scenario was really uncomfortable
for them to get uh to understand each
other so it's like something that could
be solved really easily but it's not
because you don't really speak the
language another scenario was in at an
airport here in new york i'm saying
people that are italian they don't speak
english
and it's four of them and the person at
the best doesn't really speak another
language but english so they lasted a
long time they were just bringing out
paperwork like having her see what she
didn't even know where they were going
so that's how complicated it got
and you are targeting spanish because
that's what you know
where you're gonna go i'm targeting
i'm targeting spanish
uh to other languages because
there are companies out there that do
offer this type of service but what
makes us different is the fact that we
are starting from spanish as a main
language
uh it's the combination that is
different spanish french spanish german
spanish russian versus english spanish
english and you know it's just a
different a totally different market
i'm wondering how do you make this
important enough
okay
you know like
the scenarios you're talking about are
kind of important in the moment but you
don't you don't plan for that
true you know like if i'm planning a
trip
to a spanish-speaking country
to do some business
right now i probably have some kind of
solution to do
the translation i would assume they
would have it on their side or something
like i wouldn't just go in blind
okay i'm losing a deal right if i'm
making uh like i've done a lot of
presentations
um
in spanish-speaking countries i don't
speak spanish
they always have somebody
they always have somebody there to kind
of pick me up take me to the conference
uh take care of whatever i need to get
taken care of
but i could see it kind of being helpful
in the
the the day-to-day stuff where i'm not
with somebody like i want to go to the
market you know and then like i don't
know how to buy uh whatever right but
like i wouldn't plan for that how do you
make that important because the business
stuff
uh i me i may discover you know what the
person they have sucks and i need i need
backup i need someone who i trust to
help me out
sure
like how can you tell a compelling story
so that people
plan with you
instead of
like make it more important that's what
i'm struggling with that makes sense uh
what i was just thinking is exactly that
i was thinking more like emergency kind
of situations for example your car
breaks down a company in a country that
you don't speak the language in uh
uh like you know there are apps that you
could talk into the app and they would
just relay it in a different language or
a target language to the other person
but it's not the same when you're alone
who can talk to if you're by yourself
so uh over the phone or through the app
you would be able to get a hold of an
entrepreneur who would help you out in
that kind of situation so it's more like
an emergency based kind of business i
see where you're coming from though like
if it's not that they're not a lot of
demand and
you know it's i can't just really count
on a purchase
yeah you know maybe maybe your foot in
the door is the emergency
because you're paid per use right if i
don't have an emergency i don't use you
exactly i'm paying like i'm paying by
the minute or what per call or
yeah by the minute okay so i'm paying by
the minute how much am i paying by the
minute two dollars two dollars a minute
so that's that's
reasonable you know if i'm an emergency
two bucks a minute is is not a lot um
you i would pitch this as an emergency
extra for the for the travelers
and then for people who use you and love
you you can have this additional service
where like you are you could be their
main translator you may have people
asking you like hey i'm going on a
business trip and i need someone to
translate everything for me i'm gonna
i'm gonna need you like for a full day
that's like enough style that um
that you could provide
with it but like you may not charge in
two bucks a minute anymore
you know uh what we were thinking even
about uh
like travelers insurance when people get
travelers insurance just basically add a
couple of minutes to the policy so like
if you have some kind of emergency you
just you know it you already have it in
the package so when you have that type
of thing just come up then you have
access to those minutes with for
interpretation
yeah i really see it as an emergency
thing to start because i would be
interested in that
uh
because it doesn't cost me anything
unless i use it like it makes total
sense
and then people might want to
use you for more for the for the intense
means and all that stuff like if it
comes up
let your clients take you there but you
sell it as that emergency service
you know what i want to do it's more
like following your advice and a lot of
things like i just want to get the
product up and running so that we could
create uh partnerships with other
services
like for example there's a
totally cool app it's an app that you
um i don't i just don't remember the
name of it you can actually read you
just put you just face your camera and
you put your camera towards a sign and
the app automatically like right in
front of your eyes
translates it to your language
it's completely awesome so it's like you
would add two services on the same app
probably so you know it's kind of like
finding someone or finding some company
to
uh piggyback on like like you were
saying one of your videos so what we're
trying to do is just get the product
running up and running make sure it
works
and just
add to something else
yeah i would i would look at making
partnerships like think about who who
these guys are already buying from so
any of these guys who are traveling who
are they who are they buying from they
they're they're buying from maybe
traveling
hotels event planners you know
any of these companies
are potential partners from you and
maybe you give them a small cut of what
you're doing but it could be a value add
that they offer because nobody's
offering this
right now so
it could be
you know through our partnered service
with
whatever the name of your app is
um
that's the way that they can help
sell their services over somebody else's
i'm taking notes just so you know
that's good you know we got a question
from somebody watching uh
jason jason wrote in to say how about
coming up with some meaningful taglines
and you know this this makes sense to me
because
um
you gotta make this easy for people
understand so when we first talked about
i wasn't sure who your market was and
that it was like emergency use and
there's a lot of different ways to take
it if it was focused on the government
and health or or what so having a clear
easy to understand kind of
tagline he's suggesting like easy
understanding portable understanding
just something that makes your point
personally is what he's trying to say uh
through his question i think it's a good
it's a good point um
so come up with something come up with a
tagline that
is easy to understand
and and don't get too
broad like you can have a whole bunch of
services that you offer but let your
let your clients take you there because
i don't see somebody right now
using an app
and hiring you
to do the whole like the whole full day
negotiations or full week long
negotiations
uh it could happen but off the off the
top there's a lot of established
companies that do that but i can see
your clients taking you there where if
you help them like somebody's broken
down at the side of the road they're
trying to get to their business meeting
they don't know the language
they break down they pull up the
emergency app you're there
like you save their life there you know
and and that could be it right depending
on the country
man
you're going to want to use you for
everything
right so telling these kinds of stories
so looking at
uh business travelers and going through
some scenarios where your emergency
service would help so like that renting
a car or like going to the market or you
know whatever it is like think about the
most common uses most common emergencies
that you would help with going to a
doctor all that stuff showed like a few
samples
would help really bring the point home
and and hey it's free unless you
actually run into a problem
exactly
that's true
taking notes
i like it i like it i would i would
install it man i would install that app
if you explained it like that i would
install it and uh
just as security you know just as a
backup plan
sure definitely and that's that's
something that i wanted to ask you
because you're right about something the
fact that customers take you to a point
or uh you know they just ask you
basically what they need
i wanted to ask you as an entrepreneur
because let's say you go to a
salsa convention like we were talking
about the other day to cuba or the
dominican and uh
i was wanting to know if also if someone
else is watching the video or if they
could comment like jason did that was
awesome i appreciate it jason uh someone
could just basically say what they would
like to see in the app that would help
me a whole lot because most of the
people or
we're all entrepreneurs we're all here
trying uh to go after something so that
would really help me to see what we need
if someone is in the same scenario like
what they would like to see in an app
like this
um
yeah but i mean what you might want to
do
i think the approach i would take is try
to make everything around those
emergency moments
that you have and you might even give
them some some free
sample sentences
right like
how do you say my car broke down or
something how do you say
uh where is the hospital or something
like that right if you give some free
sample sentences in spanish and then
they're loading your app to see those
sentences and then they realize the
conversation like
like i don't know what i'm doing here
right
yeah definitely
you know i say i need a doctor and then
they give me a response and i don't know
what they're saying
i'm gonna get frustrated and at that
point two dollars a minute is nothing
like i'm calling you guys but you're
giving them some some emergency
resources that they can use
um
so think about the scenarios
where people would most need to use your
product your app
and then
give some free other resources around it
that could help
you know what i was thinking about
that same point that i was going to is
those three resources and where the app
would go to
uh we were thinking of adding some kind
of uh database of the
important contacts and depending on
which country you are in for example uh
i'm always going to mention the military
public because that's where i'm from and
that's where my my company is based off
of yeah uh in the dominican republic you
have a different number for emergency
you don't call 9-1-1
9-1-1 doesn't really work
well so you need to have members for
police for hospitals for you know
different kinds of things that you as a
tourist you wouldn't be you wouldn't
know you would go to vr and you would
down 9-1-1 but it doesn't really work
very well so having resources like that
like emergency contact like embassy and
all that information just added to the
app so that people could access it yeah
maybe
would help as well absolutely that's
what you got to put it i mean and and
there's tons like those numbers are not
super difficult to add in and all of the
travel guides and all that stuff they
have it too but then i'm carrying
another thing or like i got to carry my
travel guide to the dr and and look it
up and find out where
right or or different app right so to
have it all in one place makes it super
easy and then to be able to call you if
i have a problem or a question
is great so i agree like make make it a
free app make it tons like put tons of
information and maybe it means country
by country and you started off only dr
to get started like traveling to the dr
um
just put in tons of useful information
that any
any tourists would need to know for
emergency situations and then on top of
that is your
is your uh your app where people can
call you
awesome awesome i think
um also i was thinking of maybe
targeting let's say tourists come in
they have to come through in through
somewhere so we're just basically
thinking about targeting mostly airports
whatever is possible
and the hotel because they stay
somewhere you know
so mostly they travel they just
basically go through the airports and to
a hotel and then on the way back the
same so probably adding like weather
reports or something like that i don't
know if that's overdoing it a bit that's
something that i don't want to do either
it's like when you say in your videos
you don't want to concentrate your focus
too much on things that you don't know
if they're going to be
or they're going to like so you might
end up looking kind of an effort in
something that is not going to be useful
yeah i would focus on being emergency
right like make that your first market
so like the weather
you get that everywhere you get that the
hotel i get that when i load my phone
when i land in the country it says oh
you're in france
you want to update your phone settings
yes and i get all the weather and time
and all that stuff
but uh
anything that is
helpful for like emergency situations
for somebody traveling
you want to have
on your app and ready to go and the good
news is a lot of that stuff is
it doesn't change
like the embassy phone number doesn't
change once you set it up it's up but
weather and you know other stuff that's
unrelated will constantly change the ads
more
infrastructure and more thought for you
that that isn't necessarily a big value
add
if
um
like i'd love to see i love what you
think with the partnerships
airports hotels like i don't see the
airport themselves doing something but
uh the stores within the airports like
maybe they could sell a prepaid
card
for like 20 bucks worth of time with
your service that they only like they
use it as they spend it that's it um
and then that gives them like a 10
minute call with you
or maybe it's like a discounted rate
something but but they could help sell
those things because you're right you
have a lot of travelers coming through
um
like i don't see the airport themselves
doing something but those stores i could
see them
doing something selling those cards
sure awesome depending on your partner
like
hotels or um
or
or
travel agencies they're trying to
maintain uh a connection with their
customer they care about the
relationship with their customer they're
like service-based business
so that's where
adding you to the mix
could make their offering better
so
like a travel agent
there are they're not there's not a lot
of difference in the price you're going
to get from travel agents it's more the
service so you can make their travel
agency better because your tag along
emergency service that could help seal
the deal for them so they care about
their customers
at the airport they don't care about the
customers right like those little stores
you're not gonna go i gotta go find that
guy who works at that little store right
like it's everything's overpriced and
you're just going because you actually
need something so
they won't care that you help make them
look good they want to make money so you
could sell that kind of prepaid card or
some other option where they are like in
the moment
wanting to buy something and it could be
that could be um
like they could have a home at the
airport
right
it's not even to your destination
country i'm at the airport i only speak
spanish i don't know what's going on
they could say go to that store buy the
prepaid card
right and uh you're in business
i like that i like that
you know there's you got a point there
that's true
and um
i do have the capability of doing the
prepaid cards i actually i have
discarded it because i thought that
maybe with the app it would be more
practical but you're right about that
that's that's that's an option
and um
ties into the app you still have the
app but the prepaid card just gives you
credits on the app
what i was going to do is that i still
i was going to do that instead of the
app i was going to do the prefix and
things like that but i decided like
it's it's better to launch something
that you're proud of out there like you
know just makes sure that it's great
when you make sure that it's great and
you can just throw it out there and then
you make sure that people are gonna want
it and you feel proud of that product
that you threw out
out there i think that that's um that's
better than doing something that you're
not really
you know
i don't want to start in the market with
a product that i'm going to change like
in a couple weeks later
so that's why i decided to go with the
app just from the get-go
yeah i mean
so i mean your product will end up
changing a lot as you get feedback but
the great thing about an app is you can
make changes
on the fly so it's a lot easier than
like you just order ten thousand cards
and nobody's buying them and now you're
stuck with it
i see the card as being like a phase two
for you because
you need to have something to say like
here's our app this is this is the
process and then you can buy a prepaid
card if you want to go to those stores
you have to show them
something working
sure sure definitely your launcher
and then you can have the prepaid as an
extra bonus on top of it but
partnerships are definitely a strong way
to go to build this up
awesome became great that was that's it
what's your question
like is the app ready is it is it are
you like just idea phase or how long are
we away from seeing this thing
we as you know before i was struggling
to find a developer
yeah i was just
but i definitely
finally found somebody that's reliable
and he's really you know he's really
into it so uh hopefully we're already
talking about the features that's going
to have or like what we have and what we
need so it's going to take a couple
weeks maybe uh three to four weeks for
it to launch finally okay but we're in
the process
cool yeah we'll keep you posted i'm
excited i'm going to be a user
uh hopefully i don't have to use it that
often but uh
i do i know you're there so it's good
and keep me posted and maybe we'll do
this again after you launch
awesome no we're gonna we're gonna keep
in touch seriously i'm gonna be
bombarding you with questions all the
time
thanks arturo
thank you for being there thank you for
all you do thank you very much
all right cheers